it's Monday January 27th and you're
watching gamespot news I'm Chris waters
filling in for the ailing Jess McDonald
so that you don't catch whatever she has
I may not have a good understanding of
germ theory but i do have today's top
news stories lined up so let's get to it
the Gears of War franchise has changed
meaty overmuscled hands going from being
exclusively published by Microsoft to
being entirely owned by microsoft
creator epic games sold Microsoft the
rights to all existing in future games
as well as merchandise and quote
entertainment experiences now Microsoft
own developer black tusk studios is
taking charge of the series despite
being originally founded to create new
IP and former Gears of War executive
producer rod Ferguson has joined the
studio to play a key leadership role as
for epic games they're still working on
multiple projects though the only one
they've announced thus far is fortnight
a cooperative sandbox survival game
exclusively for the PC so it looks like
we can expect another big Gears of War
announcements sometime in the coming
months which begs the question what do
you want from gears of war for the Xbox
one please direct all rampant
speculation and snarky responses to the
comment box below speaking of shooting
stuff on the Xbox one it looks like
there's going to be a titanfall beta in
about three weeks French gaming site
Xbox agenta dimma jizz indicating that
the beta will run from February 14th
through February 19th and that access
will be restricted to those who have
pre-ordered the game from participating
retailers which appear to be gamestop in
the US and Mike Romania in France though
there's no indication of what platforms
the beta will be available on titanfall
is slated to arrive on the xbox one xbox
360 and PC on march 11
from a competitive shooter coming out
soon to an RPG coming out who knows when
it's time to talk about cyberpunk 2077
in an interview with IGN CD Projekt RED
CEO marcin winski elaborated on the
studios goals for the futuristic RPG we
are known for storytelling and big game
worlds so we're taking all that we've
learned from the previous three Witcher
games as well as the open-world aspect
and applying it to cyberpunk 2077 so yes
it is an all-out RPG game but we're
looking at having a lot of new gameplay
elements that I cannot talk about yet
one thing I can say for sure is that it
is definitely not a multiplayer shooter
I guess the profusion of bullets in the
teaser trailer might suggest multiplayer
to some but come on this is CD Projekt
RED RPGs are their thing that and
weirdly catchy trailer music
two more quick ones and then we're done
the Elder Scrolls 5 skyrim has sold 20
million copies since it came out in
November 2011 leaving Tamriel northern
province dangerously overcrowded also a
simulation of superbowl48 run by EA
using madden NFL 25 has predicted the
Denver Broncos will beat the Seattle
Seahawks 31 to 28 in overtime apparently
this annual tradition has accurately
predicted eight of the ten past winners
apparently this annual tradition has
accurately predicted eight of the past
ten winners but I don't care I'm a
Patriots fan so I'm really just in it
for the commercials and with that
admission of my own callous consumerism
I'm out as always please share your
thoughts on today's stories with us in
the comments below or via twitter using
the hashtag GS news have a great week